are there stuff like uh
love and uh consciousness and all those
kinds of topics
do they come up in psych in the
knowledge base oh of course so an
important part of human knowledge in
fact it's difficult to understand human
behavior in human history without
understanding
human emotions and why people do things
and
how
how emotions drive people to to do
things and
all all of that is extremely important
in
getting psych to understand things for
example in coming up with scenarios so
one of the applications that psych does
one kind of application it does is to
generate plausible scenarios of what
might happen and what might happen based
on that and what might happen based on
that and so on so you generate this
ever-expanding sphere if you will of
possible future things to to worry about
or think about
and
in some cases those are intelligence
agencies doing uh possible terrorist
scenarios so that we can defend against
terrorist threats before we see the
first one sometimes they are computer
security
attacks so that we can actually close
loopholes
and vulnerabilities before the very
first time someone actually exploits
those
and so on sometimes they are scenarios
involving more positive things
involving
our plans like for instance what what
college should we go to what career
should we go into and so on
what professional training should i
um take on
that that sort of thing so there
there's all sorts of
um
there are all sorts of useful scenarios
that can be
generated that way of cause and effect
and cause and effect that go out
and many of the linkages
in those scenarios many of the steps
involve
understanding and reasoning
about human motivations human needs
human emotions what people are likely to
react
to in
in something that you do and why and how
and so on so that was
always a very important part of the
knowledge that we had to represent
in the system so i talk a lot about love
so i gotta ask do you remember off the
top of your head
how psych is trying to
is able to represent
various aspects of love that are useful
for understanding human nature and
therefore integrating into this whole
knowledge base of common sense what is
love we try to tease apart
concepts that
have enormous
complexities to them and variety to them
down to the level where
where you don't as it were you don't
need to tease them apart further so love
is too general of a term it's not you
exactly so when you get down to uh
romantic love and sexual attraction you
get down to parental love you get down
to
have
filial
love and
you get down to love of
uh doing some kind of activity or
creating so eventually you get down to
maybe 50 or 60 concepts
each of which is a kind of love they're
interrelated and then each one of them
has idiosyncratic
things about it
and you don't have to deal with love to
get to that level of complexity even
something like in
x being in y meaning physically in y
uh we may have one english word in to
represent that but it's useful to tease
that apart
because the way that the um the liquid
is in the coffee cup is different from
the way that the air is in the room
which is different from the way that i'm
in my jacket
and so on and so they're questions like
if i look at this coffee cup well i see
the liquid if i turn it upside down with
the liquid come out and so on
if i have say
coffee with sugar in it
if i do the same thing the sugar doesn't
come out right it stays in the liquid
because it's dissolved in the liquid and
so on so by now we have about 75
different kinds of in
in the system and it's important to
distinguish those so if you're reading
along an english
text you see the word in
the writer of that was able to use this
one innocuous word because he or she was
able to assume that the reader had
enough common sense and world knowledge
to disambiguate which of these 75 kinds
of in
they actually meant and the same thing
with love you may see the word love
but if i say you know i love ice cream
that's obviously different than if i say
i love this person or i love to
go fishing or something like that so
you have to be careful not to take
language
too seriously because people have
done a kind of parsimony a kind of
terseness where you have as few words as
as you
as you can because otherwise you'd need
half a million words in your language
which is a lot of words that's like 10
times more than most languages really
make use of and so on just like we have
on the order of
about a million concepts in
psych because we've had to tease apart
all these things and so when you look at
the name of a psych term
most of the psych terms
actually have three or four english
words in a phrase which captures the
meaning of this term
because you have to distinguish all
these types of love you have to
distinguish all these types of in
and there's not a single english word
which captures most of these things yeah
and
it seems like language when used for
communication between humans
almost as a feature has some ambiguity
built in
it's not so it's not an accident because
like the human condition is a giant mess
and so it feels like
nobody wants two robots
like very precise formal logic
conversation on a first date right
like there's some dance of like
uncertainty of what of humor of push and
pull and all that kind of stuff if
everything is made precise
then life is not worth living i think
for in terms of the the human experience
and we've all had this experience of
creatively misunderstanding
you